now I can almost hear you at home
thinking okay dudes I got it now what
one of the first things you should do is
to think on your business model
what is your profit model and how are
you going to execute against it a few
important questions that could guide you
in the right path would you or someone
you know that represent the target
audience pay this amount for that
service why are there any great
alternatives out there that are free
what is your expected burn rate how
would you control it
what is the gross margin what are the
net margin how many cells do you need to
make in order to break even what is the
worst-case scenario for your business
how would you overcome it lots of
question now well it's just a tool to
put us in the right path even if some of
these questions are not applicable to
you right now it's a good idea to
address them when you are ready